précédemment sur dtc décembre 2016 je
décide de me faire tatouer
mais il ça tourne mal [ __ ] on fait
quoi fin février 2017 je commençais
séances de laser pour me débarrasser du
tatouage une séance 2 3 4
cinq six sept séances juin 2018
je décide de changer de méthode
[Musique]
voilà donc après un an et cette séance
de laser ku switch classique j'ai décidé
de passer la vitesse supérieure avec le
laser pico shourd qui est le laser de
dernière génération pour ça j'ai aps les
rendez vous au centre saint-honoré
ponthieu dans le 8e arrondissement à
paris
donc on va faire comment fait d'habitude
j'y vais vous me suivez
et puis je reviens et en débrief allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la première différence par rapport
à d'habitude c'est que cette fois on va
me de la pommade anesthésiant bon ça
oblige à arriver un petit peu en avance
parce qu'après il faut attendre une
heure pour que la pommade agissent
[Musique]
donc j'ai attendu j'attends que j'ai
attendu
j'ai attendu une heure avant donc mais
ça valait le coup
[Musique]
je sens
sourire
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est fini alors que vous avez pu
le voir c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins
douloureux que les séances précédentes
je vais me poser chez moi et on débraye
tout ça alors on va commencer par le
début donc le laser pico jours
c'est quoi la différence bon c'est un
laser qui est plus puissant que celui
que j'avais utilisé jusqu'à présent
à la base la technique c'est la même
c'est à dire c'est un faisceau laser
donc c'est à dire de la lumière amplifié
qui va venir cogner contre les fragments
d'entre de pigments du tatouage pour la
faire exploser jusqu'à ce que les
particules soit suffisamment petites
pour être évacués par le corps avec le
premier laser que j'avais utilisé c'est
à dire le quiou switch classique est
celui qu'on retrouve le plus communément
dans les centres de détatouage les
impulsions elles étaient de l'ordre de
la nanoseconde c'est à dire en gros un
milliardième de seconde alors c'est déjà
des impulsions ultracourtes mais là avec
le pico jour on est de l'ordre de la
picoseconde d'où son nom une picoseconde
c'est un millième de milliardième de
seconde et en gros avantage c'est
qu'avec cette méthode la destruction de
langues elle est plus mécanique que
thermique 1 c'est à dire que en gros ça
chauffe moins mais ça cogne plus fort
sur les pigments et donc cette petite
précision est en fait comme vous l'avez
vu sur les images j'ai eu beaucoup moins
mal que d'habitude
alors bon comme ça picote s'applique aux
plus ou moins selon les zones et des
endroits où c'est plus sensibles mais
c'est vraiment sans comparaison
il paraît que le pico shourd est moins
douloureux que le cul switch classique
moi je peux pas juger parce que là
contrairement aux fois précédentes on
m'a mis de la pommade anesthésiante donc
c'est notamment pour ça que j'ai très
très peu senti donc mon conseil est déjà
si vous vous faites des tatoués un jour
exigé qu'on vous mette de la pommade
anesthésiante 1 sauf
vous aimez tout ce qui est douleur si
vous aimer souffrir alors deux autres
avantages annoncés depuis toujours parce
qu'évidemment on jugera tous ensemble si
les promesses sont tenues
c'est que d'abord il faut moins de
séances que avec le classique pour se
débarrasser du tatouage là on m'a
annoncé quatre séances et puis aussi il
ya besoin d'attendre moins longtemps
entre deux séances à dire qu'avec
l'autre c'était deux mois là c'est tous
les mois
pourquoi parce qu'en fait le laser est
censé être moins agressif avec la avec
la peau donc en cicatrice plus
rapidement donc on peut y retourner plus
vite donc on récapitule on a un nouveau
laser qui est censée être plus efficace
que le précédent
un nouveau tarif puisque la 7 300 euros
la séance
au lieu de 150 mais avec moins de séance
a priori une séance par mois pendant
quatre mois
ce qui veut dire que vous allez voir
m'ont fait si régulièrement cet été et
le verdict ce sera pour la rentrée
mais bon je vais pas vous faire languir
plus longtemps un jeu c'est pourquoi
vous êtes là le moment que vous
attendiez toutes et tous
voilà les photos alors ça c'est le
tatouage juste avant la séance
ça c'est le tatouage juste après le
laser ça c'est le tatouage le lendemain
ça c'est le tatouage
deux jours après ça c'est le tatouage
trois jours après et ça c'est le
tatouage au bout de quatre jours
attention c'est trop tôt on est d'accord
pour juger de l'efficacité du laser
alors pour deux raisons on en a déjà
parlé mais je vous refais la petite
petite explication pour imaginer que les
particules d'encre dans les pigments
sous la peau c'est des petits bouts de
chardon avait comme ce qu'on met dans le
dans le barbecue
le médecin il a tapé dessus avec son
petit marteau au laser et il a réduit
certains pigments en poudre il faut le
temps déjà que cette poudre soit évacué
donc ça se voit pas immédiatement
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire en
regardant des vidéos des tatouages sur
internet et puis aussi bas il ya des
morceaux de charbon qui sont plus denses
plus résistants que les que les autres
donc cela il faut y retourner pour
taper dessus voilà c'est pour ça qu'il
ya besoin de plusieurs séances dont ce
qu'on va faire c'est que j'y retourne
dans un bois dont on jugera tous
ensemble à ce moment-là de l'efficacité
du truc et puis bon bah évidemment on
jugera séance après séance puisque là
comme avec l'ancien laser il a commencé
doucement et il va augmenter un peu la
puissance au fur et à mesure des rendez
vous donc vous avez compris on se
retrouve dans un mois pour une nouvelle
séance de laser
on verra bien d'ici là je ne vais pas
vous plantez on va continuer à faire des
vidéos
donc en attendant qu'est ce qu'on fait
je vous en supplie 1 mettez vous bien et
surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]